being able to do this new version of
Thor it's hugely liberating and fun we
had a big set of fat suit which i think
was sort of sixty or seventy pounds it
was the hottest I've ever been and we
had to the beard the hair and had these
things that go in the mouth they're kind
of plump out my cheeks a bit which sort
of had a little effect on the voice as
well but probably eating a good boy it
was it was a different for I'm still 22
years old everyone asked God and I like
sugar we're shooting a superhero film
and here's one of the most recognizable
superheroes but he's just turned into a
new character what Chris does with that
character and how it just kind of heads
this shift his excitement was really
palpable being playing the character for
a while and really wanted to find
something new
he has such dexterity as a talent he's
incredibly funny he's just really lovely
energy is he asleep no no I'm pretty
sure he's dead
nobody pull a hamstring the thing about
time travel
I can't believe I made a whole movie
with this thing yeah look cooler doesn't
feel cool but if it looks cool as a
virus you have any idea what's coursing
through my veins right now son yawns yes
orange Satan
we are getting the whole team aren't we
[Music]
see that doing here 10 years of it
you